بنت مجموعه العشرين بيحزمن الحربه في
اوكرانيا لكنها اشارت الى وجودي وجوهات
نظر اخرى وقالت المجموعه في البيان
الختامي لقمتها التي عقد في جزيره بالي
اندونيسيا ان غالبيه الدول للاعضاء فيها
تعتبر ان هذا النزاع يقود الاقتصاد
العالمي اكدت المجموعه ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا تتسبب في معاناه الانسانيه كبيره
واكد الدول المجموعه ان استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه او التهديد باستخدامها غير مسموح
به
معنا من بالي مراسل الجزيره صهيب جاسم اذا
صهيب عكس الكثير من التوقعات البياني يندد
بالحرب الروسيه رغم وجود وجهات نظر كما
جاء في البيان حديثنا اكثر عن التفاصيل
بخصوص هذه النقطه
[موسيقى]
منذ يوم امس بل حتى منذ بدايه هذا العام
في لقاءات المتعدده وزاريه تحضيريه في
مجالات مختلفه جاء البيان بشكل او باخر
توافقيا لم يستنكر البيان روسيا وانما
استنكر الحرب في اوكرانيا وكانه حاول
احتواء اراء الدول الاسيويه مثل الهند
والصين والاندونيسيا وحتى الدول في امريكا
اللاتينيه البيان يقول ان معظم الاعضاء
يستنكرون الحرب في اوكرانيا واكدوا انها
تتسبب في معاناه انسانيه كبيره وتعمق
هشاشه الوضع الاقتصادي كما ذكرته في
المقدمه وتعرقل النمو الاقتصادي وتزيد
التضخم وتضر بسلاسل حركه السلع وتفاقمه من
اضعاف الامن من امن طاقه والغذاء وكان
وظيفه عباره بانه كانت هناك اراء مختلفه
او تقدير مختلفه الوضع والعقبات
فقط في ثلاث فقرات الحرف في اوكرانيا في
نفس الفقره قال مع الادراك بان جماعه
العشرين ليست المنتدى لحل المشاكل الامنيه
فاننا نقر بان القضايا الامنيه قد يكون
لها اثر عظيمه او عواقب كبيره على
الاقتصاد العالمي ومع الخوف من اي ما من
قضيه الحرب النوويه والتهديد باي شيء مثل
ذلك قالوا قالت قال قال البيان انه لابد
من الالتزام بقانون الدولي والنظام الدولي
المتعدد والحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار
وان استخدام او التهديد الاستخدام او
التهديد باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه امر غير
مقبول وان التسويه السلميه للصراعات
والجهود المبذوله للتعامل مع الازمه وكذلك
الدبلوماسيه والحوار في غايه الاهميه ولا
يجب ان تكون هناك حرب في عصرنا في الفقره
الثامنه كان هناك اشاره لاتفاقيه اسطنبول
الخاصه بتصدير الحبوب والاسمده وكان هناك
دعم لتمديد هذه الاتفاقيه ايضا كان هذا
الامر جائع في المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حيث يؤكد على انه
عندما يعود الى اسطنبول سيبحث تمديد هذه
الاتفاقيه وقال انه هذا ضروريه بالطبع هذا
الامر يهم دول مجموعه ال 20 حيث انه يتحدث
عن 60% من السكان من سكان الارض هم داخل
هذه المجموعه 75% من طالب على الطاقه
والطالب على والاقتصاد والتجاره العالميه
هي في هذه المجموعه وتمارين في المئه من
الناتج المحليه الاجمالي لدول العالم في
هذه المجموعه لان هناك اهتمام بهذه القضيه
الحبوب والاسمده وتصديرها والاستقرار
وخروج من الحرب الحرب التي ربما ادرت
بكثير من اتصالات العالم ومنها اقتصارات
الاسيويه هنا في هذه المنطقه وحتى في
مناطق مختلفه لاحظنا هذا اليوم ان هذه
الحرب يعني لم تنفك عن هذا عن هذه القمه
خلال يومين تاخر الاجتماع
الجلسه الختاميه الى الى هذه الساعه بسبب
الاجتماع الطارئ للاذاعه اليه الرئيس
الامريكي بعيدا لمناقشه الانفجار الذي وقع
في بولندا لكن حذرا واضحا في تصريحات
الرئيس بايدا حيث انه استبعد ان يكون
الامر من روسيا وكذلك في بيان الاتحاد
الناته ودول السبع الكبار الحاضرين في دول
ال 20 وهم سبعه من ضمنهم اليابان هم طبعا
استنكروا همم ما حصل من هجوم على بولندا
وايمانكر تصعيد الروسي على اوكرانيا
الماضي او يوم امس ولكنهم لم يستطيعوا
باظهار هذا الموقف في بيان مجموعه ال20
في في في في مكان واحد
توافقين في البيان كما ذكرنا وموقف واضح
لدول الناتو ومجموعه السبع الكبار الذين
يشكلون ربما القوه الاقتصاديه الاكبر من
ناحيه العالم الغربي اضافه الى اليابان
لكن الدول الناميه بما فيها الهند والصين
واندونيسيا والبرازيل كل هذه الدول حتى
الارجنتين وغيرها وجنوب افريقيا هذه الدول
لم تضع يديها في نفس الاتجاه في استنكار
روسيا وانما اراد ان تخرج بموقف استنكار
لمبدا الحرب بغض النظر عن استنكار من كما
لاحظنا ان ايضا اشرفنا في نشرات سابقه ان
هذه القمه كانت قمه اللقاءات الثنائيه
المهمه من ابرز هذه اللقاءات الثنائيه
التي عقدها الرئيس الصيني فيجن مع كثير من
الاطراف ربما هي اكثر الاكثر اللقاءات
اتساعا منذ ما قبل كورونا منذ قبل وبعد
كرونا والشغاء العالم بهذا الوباء وقله
اللقاءات الثنائيه الرئيس الفلسطيني
التقاعد الرئيس الامريكي والرئيس الوزراء
الاسترالي كان اول لقاء بينهما منذ خمس
سنوات تقريبا
في امريكا
اللاتينيه واعتبرت هذه القمه ربما جزءا من
الدبلوماسيه الصينيه في المنطقه وفي غيرها
من الدول العالم تواصلا متجددا بعد سنتين
من الوباء
الاندونيسي